Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Subsurface scattering means that a portion
of light that hits a translucent material
does not bounce back from the surface but
penetrates it and scatters many-many times
inside the material.
Now, if you have a keen eye, you recognize
that there are a lot of materials in real
life that have subsurface scattering.
Many don't know, but our skin is a great example
of that, and so is marble, milk, wax, plant
leaves, apple and many others.
If you would like to hear a bit more about
subsurface scattering, check the second part
of the video that you see recommended in the
corner of this window, or just click it in
the description box below.
Subsurface scattering looks unbelievably beautiful,
but at the same time, it is very expensive
because we have to simulate up to thousands
and thousands of scattering events for every
ray of light.
It really takes forever.
And if you'd like to tweak your material settings
just a bit because the result is not a 100%
up to your taste, you have to recreate, or
what graphics people like to say, re-render
these images.
It's not really a convenient workflow.
This piece of work offers a great solution
where you have to wait a bit longer than you
would wait for one image, but only once, because
it runs a generalized light simulation, and
after that, whatever changes you apply to
your materials, you will see immediately.
You can also paint the reflectance properties
of this material that we call albedos and
get results with full subsurface scattering
immediately.
Here is another interactive editing workflow
where you get results instantaneously, and
the result with this technique is indistinguishable
from the real deal, which would be re-rendering
this result image every time some adjustment
is made.
With this technique, you can really create
the materials you thought up in a fraction
of the time of the classical workflow.
Spectacular work.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!